FEMALE ANNOUNCER: The following
content is provided
under a Creative Commons
license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi.
In our last few lectures we were
trying to establish the
identity of integral calculus
and differential calculus in
their own right, independently
of one another, and then by
the fundamental theorems of
integral calculus to show the
amazing relationship between
these two subjects.
Now what we would like to do
today is to emphasize this
topic in terms of an application
unlike what we've
been doing before.
In particular, what we will do
today is discuss the question
of finding volumes.
And in doing this, several
interesting things should
happen, not the least of which
is that we will rederive
certain results that we've been
taking for granted about
solid regions--
volumes of regions--
for quite awhile.
And also, it will give us an
excellent chance to understand
what we really mean by a
mathematical structure.
Well, at any rate, to emphasize
the structure part,
I've called today's lesson,
'3-dimensional Area'.
See, instead of calling
it volume, I call it
3-dimensional area, and the
reason for this is I'd like to
show you how one can study
volumes in a completely
analogous way to how
we studied areas.
Remember, we had three basic
assumptions for area.
I'm now going to assume three
similar assumptions for volume
except where I have to amend
them by necessity.
And the only place this
amendment has to take place is
whereas the rectangle was the
basic building block of areas,
the so-called cylinder
will be the basic
building block of volumes.
Let me take a moment to digress
here and explain to
you mathematically what the
mathematician calls a cylinder.
We start with any closed curve,
say, in a plane, and we
then take a line perpendicular
to that plane.
And with that line we trace
along the curve.
And we then take another plane
parallel to the plane that the
curve is in and slice this
thing off someplace.
In other words, by definition, a
cylinder has congruent cross
sections all the way through.
And what we're saying is that--
in fact, the familiar
form of a cylinder is the
one where the cross
section is a circle.
That's called the right
circular cylinder.
Remember, the volume of a right
circular cylinder is 'pi
r squared h', the area
of the cross
section times the height.
Well, that's the generalization
that we make.
In other words, our first
assumption is that for any
cylinder the volume of
the cylinder is the
cross-sectional area
times the height.
Or you could call it the area of
the base times the height,
since the cross-sectional area
is the same for all slices.
OK?
The next assumption says, if we
think of volume as meaning
the amount of space only in
three dimensions, whereas area
means the amount of space in
two dimensions, our next
assumption is that if the three
dimensional region 'R'
is contained in the three
dimensional region 'S', then
the volume of 'R' is less than
or equal to the volume of 'S'.
And finally, we assume an
analogous result about the
area of the whole equals the sum
of the areas of the parts.
We assume that if a region is
made up of the union of 'n'
regions which do not overlap--
notice the union
notation here.
The union of 'R sub 1' up to 'R
sub n' and if the 'R's do
not overlap, then the volume of
the region 'R' is the sum
of the volumes of the
constituent parts.
In other words, notice that
except for the fact that
cylinder replaces rectangle, the
basic axioms for studying
volume are precisely the
same as the axioms
for studying area.
In particular, then, what this
means is that structurally the
same results that we were able
to show for area should follow
word for word, essentially,
for volumes.
And I thought what we would
do is start with a rather
familiar example.
You may recall--
of course, we've used this
result many times--
that the volume of a cylinder
is given by 1/3--
that the volume of a cone is
'1/3 pi r squared h' where 'r'
is the radius of the base
and 'h' is the height.
And you may remember that
in solid geometry as a
traditional high school
curriculum went, these results
were given but seldom
if ever proved.
So what I thought we would do
now is see how we can use
these axioms to arrive at these
results, and to get the
spirit of what we've been trying
to do, I will do this
by integral calculus at least
first and then by differential
calculus later.
But the idea is something
like this.
To visualize the cone, the
radius of whose base is 'r'
and whose height is 'h', we can
think of the straight line
that joins the origin to the
point (r, h), this region
here, this right triangle.
And we can think of that as
being revolved about the
x-axis to give the cone.
Now when we were dealing with
areas, you may recall that we
broke things down into
rectangles that were too big,
rectangles that were too small,
and we computed, say,
'U sub n' and 'L sub
n', et cetera.
We can do the same thing now.
What we do is we again
circumscribe rectangles.
Now the idea is whatever volume
is traced out by this
piece here, whatever volume is
traced out when we rotate this
triangle about the x-axis, that
volume will be less than
the volume generated by this
particular rectangle, because,
you see, the volume that we're
looking for is contained
inside the rectangle when we
revolve this particular thing.
Now notice that this particular
rectangle when
revolved gives me a right
circular cylinder, and we're
assuming that we know how to
find the volume of a cylinder.
It's the cross sectional
area times the height.
Let's focus our attention on
what I call the k-th region
here and see what this
thing looks like.
First of all, notice that if
we've divided this length,
which is 'h' units long into 'n'
equal parts, each of these
pieces is 'h' over 'n'.
Secondly, notice that the radius
of the base of the
cylinder that we're going to
get-- well, let's see.
It's going to be this
y-coordinate.
Given the x-coordinate, 'y' is
determined by multiplying the
x-coordinate by 'r/h'.
The x-coordinate is
'kh' over 'n'.
I multiply that by 'r/h'.
That gives me 'kr' over 'n'.
That's the height of this--
the radius of the base
of the cylinder that
we're going to revolve.
Now what is the volume
of this cylinder?
The area of the base is 'pi y
squared', and I'm now going to
multiply that by the height,
which is 'h/n'.
And if I do that,
I obtain what?
The volume of this particular
cylinder is 'pi r squared h'
times 'k squared'
over 'n cubed'.
And now, if I add up all of
these volumes as 'k' goes from
1 to 'n', that will give me a
bunch of stacked cylinders
which enclose my cone.
In other words, an answer
that will be too
large will be what?
This sum as 'k' goes from 1 to
'n', notice that this is the
only portion that depends
on 'k', so the upper
approximation--
in other words, the volume
that's too large to be the
right answer--
is 'pi r squared h' over 'n
cubed' times the sum as 'k'
goes from 1 to 'n',
'k squared''.
Now you notice I always stick
to problems where we have
something fairly simple like
this, because this limit
process, as we've mentioned in
the previous lectures, becomes
very, very difficult to do in
general, the beauty or one of
the beauties of our fundamental
theorem.
But the idea is I do know that
this sum is 'n' times 'n + 1'
times '2n + 1' over 6.
Now distributing the 'n cubed'
one factor at a time, the way
we have before, I can now write
that this is '1/6 pi r
squared h'.
'n + 1' over 'n'
is '1 + '1/n''.
'2n + 1' over 'n'
is '2 + '1/n''.
And I find that my upper
approximation is given by this
expression.
And if I now take the limit of
'U sub n' as 'n' goes to
infinity, this factor
approaches 1.
This factor approaches 2.
Therefore, our entire product
approaches in the limit '1/3
pi r squared h', which
is the familiar
result of solid geometry.
Of course, we've taken a lot
for granted over here.
What we've really proven here
is not that the volume of a
cone is '1/3 pi r squared h'.
What we have proven is at the
limit of 'U sub n' as 'n'
approaches infinity, it's
'1/3 pi r squared h'.
The question that comes up is
how do you know that as these
divisions get small
that the volume--
the upper approximation gets
arbitrarily close to the
correct answer.
And again, notice how we can
reason analogously to what we
did in the case of area.
Namely, what we could do next,
you see, is take the smallest
cylinder that can be
inscribed here.
In other words, this would give
us an approximation which
is too small.
The total error is no more than
the solid generated by
this hatch region revolving
about the x-axis.
Notice, however, that each of
these pieces fits very nicely
in here, so that the total error
between an approximation
which is too big and an
approximation which is too
small is this height,
which is 'r'.
OK?
Let's see, the cross-sectional
area-- this is 'r'.
So 'pi r squared' is the
area of the base.
The height is 'h/n'.
Notice that 'r' and 'h' are
given constants, therefore, as
'n' goes to infinity, the
numerator stays constant.
The denominator goes
to infinity.
The difference goes to 0.
In other words, again, we can
show that 'U sub n' and 'L sub
n' have a common limit.
In fact, we can generalize this
result rather nicely.
Take this drawing to be whatever
you'd like it to be.
I've simply tried to visualize
here a solid region.
This is a 3-dimensional
region.
It has various cross sections.
And I know that as I look at it
in the 'x' direction, the
region begins at 'x' equals
'a' and terminates at 'x'
equals 'b'.
And the question is how can
I find the volume of this
particular region, assuming I
know the cross-sectional area
for any slice?
And the idea, again, is what?
We can slice this solid up into
'n' parts, which I call
'delta V1' up to 'delta Vn'.
The sum of these would be
the true volume that
we're looking for.
Now, I focus my attention on
the k-th piece here, and
again, what I do is I inscribe
and circumscribe cylinders,
one of which is contained
entirely within 'delta V sub
k', and the other of which
surrounds 'delta V sub k'.
In other words, what I do is is
I find the biggest possible
cross-sectional area I have in
this interval, and I denote
the 'x' value at which that
occurs by 'M sub k'.
I find the value of 'x', which
I call 'm sub k', at which I
get the smallest cross-sectional
area.
And therefore, the inscribed
cylinder has
volume given by this.
The circumscribed cylinder has
volume given by this, and the
piece that I'm looking for,
the true volume, is caught
between these two.
Therefore, if I add these up
as 'k' goes from 1 to 'n',
I've caught 'V' between 'U
sub n' and 'L sub n'.
Assuming only that the area is
a continuous function, the
difference between the largest
cross section and the smallest
cross section approaches 0 as
'delta x sub k' approaches 0.
In essence then, the same as
we did before, what we can
show is that as 'n' goes to
infinity, both 'U sub n' and
'L sub n' approach a common
limit, and therefore, the 'V'
being caught between these two
is equal to the common limit.
Now here's the interesting
point.
When we talked about the
definite integral, no one
asked physically what the
function 'f' was or what the
'c sub k's that we're using here
were, only that they be
in the proper interval and 'f'
be a continuous function.
Notice that we're assuming
that 'A' is continuous.
In essence then, by the
definition of the definite
integral, that volume
is just what?
The definite integral from 'a'
to 'b', 'f of x' 'dx'.
In other words, it's this sum
taken in the limit as 'n'
approaches infinity, or another
way of saying that, as
the maximum 'delta X sub
k' approaches 0.
That, by the way, is the
integral calculus approach.
If we want the differential
calculus approach, remember
what we do, we say look it.
The change in volume is less
than or equal to the maximum
cross-sectional area times
'delta X' and greater than or
equal to the minimum
cross-sectional area
times 'delta X'.
Same as we did for area,
you see, we divide
through by 'delta X'.
We have that 'delta V' divided
by 'delta X' is caught between
'A of M', 'A of m', where 'm'
and 'M' are in this interval.
And now you see as 'delta X'
approaches 0, 'm' and 'M' both
approach 'x'.
You see the same procedure
as we had before.
You see what we're saying going
back to this diagram is,
for example, here is a 'delta
X', and 'm' and 'M' are points
in here, and as 'delta X' goes
to 0, 'm' and 'M' both
approach the end point 'x'.
And since 'A' is assumed to be
continuous, if 'M' and 'm'
approach 'x', 'A of M', 'A of
m' approach 'A of x', and we
arrive at, by differential
calculus, that 'dV dx' is 'A
of x', and therefore, 'V' is
again equal to integral ''A of
x' 'dx'' as 'x' goes
from 'a' to 'b'.
Where now by differential
calculus, this means what?
It simply means 'G of b' minus
'G of a', where 'G' is any
function whose derivative
is 'f'.
Now again, I have to go through
this thing rather
hurriedly because I want to
get some examples done.
But what I hope is that we went
slowly enough so that you
can again sense how we're
using integral calculus,
differential calculus, and the
relationship between them.
Let's, at any rate, illustrate
some of these results more
concretely in terms of--
well, first of all, let's talk
about one particular type of
solid, what's called a
solid of revolution.
That's the particular type of
solid where you have a region
in the 'xy' plane, and you take
that region and rotate it
either around the x-axis or the
y-axis, thus generating a
3-dimensional region.
See, in other words, a plane
area is rotated through 360
degrees either with respect to
the x-axis or the y-axis.
I'll consider the x-axis here.
Notice that this is a special
case of what we've just
studied, namely, in this
particular case, if 'y' equals
'f of x' is a continuous
function, notice that every
cross section here, every cross
section will be a circle.
The area of the circle
is 'pi y squared'.
That's 'pi 'f of x' squared'.
And therefore, according to our
fundamental theorem, since
the area is continuous--
and why is the area
continuous?
Well, if 'f' is continuous,
remember the product of
continuous functions
is continuous.
If 'f' is continuous, 'f
squared' is continuous.
So according to our result, the
volume of the region 'R'
is just the integral from
'a' to 'b', 'pi 'f
of x' squared' 'dx'.
And you see, using differential
calculus, all we
need now is a function whose
derivative is 'pi 'f of x'
squared', and we call
that function 'G'.
We compute 'G of b' minus 'G
of a' and that gives us the
volume that we're looking for.
Remember, when we talked about
areas, we mentioned this was
highly specialized.
What if you had a region
like this?
And again, sparing the details,
observe that if we
have a region like this, we can
draw in the lines where
the curve doubles back.
We can now visualize this
as the volume--
the difference of two volumes.
Namely, we can find this volume
and subtract from that
volume this volume.
See, in other words, both of
these have the right form.
And by this difference,
what's left?
The difference of the big volume
minus the small volume
is the volume generated
by 'R'.
And as I say, these are rather
simple details that we can
check out computationally in
terms of exercises, but the
reason I wanted to mention the
solid of revolution is that
not only is this a rather common
and important category,
but it also happens to be the
type of solid that we opened
our program with.
Remember, the cone may
be viewed as what?
The solid generated by a
particular right triangle
being revolved about
the x-axis.
In fact, I thought we could
try that same problem now
doing it by the antiderivative
method.
Namely, we take this particular
region 'R' and
notice now, if we revolve
this about the x-axis--
let's see, the cross-sectional
area will be what?
Well, it's a circle
of radius 'y'.
For a given value of 'x',
'y' is equal to 'r'
times 'x' over 'h'.
See the slope of this
line is 'r/h'.
It passes through
the origin here.
So the cross-sectional area
is 'y squared' times pi.
That's 'pi 'r squared h'
squared' over 'h squared'
times 'x squared'.
And to find that volume,
I simply integrate this
between 0 and 'h'.
Recalling that pi, 'r', and 'h'
are constants, I can take
the constants outside of
the integral sign.
The integral of 'x squared',
meaning what?
The inverse derivative
is '1/3 x cubed'.
If I evaluate that between 0 and
'h', I get '1/3 h cubed'.
The 'h cubed' in the numerator
cancels the 'h squared' in the
denominator, leaving a factor of
'h' in the numerator, and I
wind up, as I saw before, that
the volume of this cone is
'1/3 pi r squared h'.
And this is nice that I get
the same answer as by the
limit method, because according
to the fundamental
theorem, the first fundamental
theorem, this is precisely
what was supposed to happen.
In other words, I can do these
either by limits or by
derivatives.
I want you to see these things
side by side, because in
certain cases, as I've
emphasized in the previous
lectures, there will be times
when we cannot, by
differential calculus, find a
function 'G' whose derivative
is equal to a given
function 'f of x'.
But enough about that
for the time being.
The next question that comes up
gives us a review of what
happens with inverse
functions.
It's a rather interesting
type of situation.
It's called the method of
cylindrical shells and it's
motivated by the following.
Let's suppose again we're given
a very nice region 'R'.
What do I mean by very nice?
Well, to simplify the
computation, even though it
doesn't change the theory at
all, I'm assuming that 'y'
equals 'f of x' is an
increasing curve.
In other words, I'm even
assuming that we have a
one-to-one function here.
Now the idea is here's this
nice region and instead of
revolving this about the
x-axis, I would like to
revolve it about the y-axis.
Now you see, to use the method
of revolution here, to revolve
this about the y-axis,
essentially what I do is I
pick a washer-shaped
region, you see?
I have to compute the volume
generated by the 'y' part.
See, in other words, I do this
as two separate parts.
I find the volume of the big
piece minus the volume of the
small piece, and what's
left is the volume
generated by 'R'.
But notice a rather difficult
computational
thing occurs here.
Namely, notice that this
length here has to be
expressed as 'x' goes from one
value to another value.
Now, you see, if this is 'b',
and this is 'a', you see,
notice what's happening
here, how our
strips are being chosen.
You see, for a given strip, the
final 'x' value is 'b',
but what is the initial
'x' value?
See, down here the 'x'
value is 'a', but
what happens up here?
In other words, how do you find
what the 'x' value is for
a given value of 'y' here?
Well, you see what you must do
is invert the relationship.
Now even though I've
picked a case
where the inverse exists--
see, this is a one-to-one
function--
we've already had ample examples
in which we've shown
that computationally it's
extremely difficult if it's
even possible to explicitly
perform the inversion.
And this is where the method
of cylindrical
shells comes from.
Essentially what the method of
cylindrical shells says is
wouldn't it have been nice if
we chose our generating
element to be this way?
In other words, what we say
is look at this piece
of area over here.
One way of visualizing this
solid being rotated is to
think of this particular region
being rotated about the
x-axis, and it generates
a certain volume.
By the way, what volume
will it generate?
The volume that it will generate
will be less than the
volume that this rectangle
generates but greater than the
here generates.
Now what is the volume
generated
by the large rectangle?
And, by the way, notice that I
mean by the volume generated
by the rectangle think of this
as being a slab of a certain
amount of material and I
rotate that slab around
through 360 degrees.
The volume I'm thinking of is
the volume of the material in
that slab, not the material
that's enclosed.
It would be like, if
you're thinking in
terms of a tin can.
I'm not thinking of the volume
enclosed by the tin can.
I'm thinking of the volume
of the tin itself that
makes up the can.
Well, you see again, to go
through this thing as rapidly
as possible but still hitting
the main points, you see,
notice that the volume that I'm
looking for, what is the
volume that's cut out by
this big rectangle?
Well, notice that the area of
the base from-- if I look at
this as being this cylinder
minus this cylinder, the
volume of the big cylinder is
pi times ''x + delta X'
squared' times the height
here, which is 'f
of 'x + delta X'.
And the volume of the
hollow part from
here to here is what?
It's 'pi x squared'--
that's the radius
of the base--
times the height, which is still
'f of 'x + delta X''.
In other words, 'delta V' is
bounded above by this volume.
In other words, as messy as this
looks, that's only what?
That's the volume of the region
generated by this big rectangle.
If we take the smallest
rectangle, namely the one
that's inscribed inside this
region, we get the same
results, except that the height
is now replaced by 'f
of x' rather than by 'f
of 'x + delta X''.
In other words, we catch
'delta V' between two
expressions involving 'x'.
By the way, notice how the
bracketed expression
simplifies the 'pi x squared'
here cancels with the 'pi x
squared' here leaving inside the
parentheses just '2x delta
X' plus 'delta X squared'.
In other words, simplifying
this thing, I can now show
that 'delta V' is caught between
these two expressions
now, this expression here, which
is too big, and this
expression here, which
is too small.
Now I divide by 'delta X'.
The usual procedure to find
'dV dx', it's 'delta V'
divided by 'delta X'.
Then I will take the limit as
'delta X' approaches 0.
You see, so I divide through
by 'delta X'.
We're assuming, of course,
that 'delta X' is not 0.
That's what the limit means
as 'delta X' approaches 0.
You see, it's not zero, but it
gets arbitrarily close to 0.
Notice then that my 'delta V'
divided by 'delta X' is caught
between pi times '2x + delta X'
times 'f of 'x + delta X'',
and pi times '2x + delta
X' times 'f of x'.
And I now let 'delta
X' approach 0.
And here's the key point.
As 'delta X' approaches 0,
notice that the left hand side
becomes '2 pi x'
times 'f of x'.
Notice also what happens
to the right hand side.
This factor, as 'delta X'
approaches 0, becomes '2x'.
And because 'f' is continuous,
as 'delta X' approaches 0, 'f
of 'x + delta X'' approaches
'f of x'.
In other words, then, in the
limit, as 'delta X' approaches
0, I have that 'dV dx' on the
one hand can't be any greater
than '2 pi x' times 'f of x'.
On the other hand, it can't
be any less than '2 pi
x' times 'f of x'.
Consequently, it must equal
'2 pi x' times 'f of x'.
Therefore, if this is 'dV dx',
then 'V' itself is the
integral of this thing evaluated
between 'a' and 'b',
because that's where we're
adding these things up from.
In other words, if we're using
differential calculus, this is
'G of b' minus 'G of a' where
'G prime' equals 'f'.
If we're using integral
calculus, we've found the 'U
sub n' and 'L sub n' and we've
caught 'V' between 'U sub n'
and 'L sub n'.
But, in any event, what we've
shown rigorously now is that
by the cylindrical shell
method-- and we'll illustrate
these with examples to finish
off today's lesson--
that the volume is given
by integral from 'a'
to 'b' '2 pi x'--
and let me just replace
'f of x' by 'y' to
make my diagram simpler--
times 'dx'.
And if you want to think of
this in what I call the
traditional engineering point
of view where you think of a
thin rectangle generating a
volume, what we're saying is
if you think of a little thin
piece like this being revolved
to generate, say, some material
in a tin can, notice
that the amount of material
in here will be what?
Well, when you unroll
this thing--
see, this thing sort
of like this.
When you unroll this thing,
the radius is 'x', so the
circumference when you unroll
it will be '2 pi x'.
The height is 'y'.
So the cross-sectional area
is '2 pi x y' and the
thickness is 'dx'.
So if I multiply that by dx,
that gives me the volume
generated by this piece.
And then in the proud tradition
of the sigma
notation, which I'll come back
to in the next lecture to show
how dangerous this really
is, but the
shortcut method is what?
Add up all of these
contributions as 'x' goes from
'a' to 'b'.
At any rate, that's called the
method of cylindrical shells.
Essentially, one uses
cylindrical shells when we
think of a generating element
being parallel
to the axis of rotation.
We use revolution, when
it's perpendicular
to the axis of rotation.
Which of the two is easier
depends on the particular
computational technique
necessitated by the
relationship between the
variables in the problem.
Well, at any rate, let's do
a couple of examples.
The first example I'd like to do
is to take that same region
'R', namely, the right
triangle whose
legs are 'r' and 'h'.
We've already solved this
problem of finding the volume
when we rotate this
about the x-axis.
What I'd now like to do is see
what volume is generated by
this as I rotate it
about the y-axis.
And again, I find that I can
do this problem in several
ways, but I thought it was an
easy enough problem to do by
cylindrical shells, because, as
we so often do, I thought
the first problem that we do by
cylindrical shells should
be one that we can check
by another method.
But at any rate, using
cylindrical shells, let's see
what happens over here.
The volume is what?
It's the integral from 0 to
'h', '2 pi x' times this
height, which is 'rx'
over 'h' integrated
with respect to 'x'.
That's just '2 pi r' over
'h'-- we can take that
outside, because that's
a constant factor--
integral 'x squared dx'.
The integral of 'x squared'
is '1/3 x cubed'.
We evaluate that between
0 and 'h'.
That gives us '1/3 h cubed'.
We cancel the 'h' in the
denominator with one of the
'h's in the numerator, and we
find that the volume that's
generated is '2/3 pi r h
squared', not 'r squared h',
'r h squared', not 1/3, 2/3.
Remember, by the way, what
this thing looks like.
I think you can visualize
this.
This is a cylinder with
a cone cut out of it.
See, in other words, if this
thing had been solid, we'd
have called it a right circular
cylinder, and then
what's missing is the cone
shaped region over here.
In fact, that's how
we can check this.
See, what would the
volume be that's
generated by this rectangle?
This would be a cylinder the
radius of whose base is 'h',
whose height is 'r', and the
volume of that cylinder is 'pi
h squared r'.
The cone that's missing, the
cone that was cut out of this
thing, has the radius of a space
equal to 'h' and its
height equal to 'r', so
its volume is '1/3
pi h squared r'.
And, therefore, the volume
that's left when we subtract
this off is '2/3 pi h
squared r', which
does check with this.
By the way, just as an aside,
notice that the region 'R'
generates a different volume
if we rotate it about the
y-axis than it did if we rotate
it about the x-axis.
Numerically, what we're saying
is that we just found that the
volume when rotated around
the y-axis is '2/3
pi h squared r'.
We know that when we revolve
that about the x-axis, it's
'1/3 pi r squared h',
and these two
expressions are not identical.
In fact, if we divide both sides
by 'pi r h' over 3, we
find that equality holds only
if we have that highly
specialized case that '2h'
equals 'r', which is not
really important.
I just threw that
in as an aside.
But I do want you to notice that
the same area, of course,
generates different volumes
depending on what you rotate
it with respect to.
Well, at any rate, at least
this was a problem that we
could check by another method.
Let me just use cylindrical
shells for a problem which is
slightly tougher but one that
can still be checked by
another method.
Let's take the following
region.
Let's take the curve 'y'
equals '2x - x squared'
between 'x' equals 0
and 'x' equals 2.
Leaving the details as a rather
trivial exercise, it is
not difficult to see that this
is the parabola that peaks at
1, 1 and crosses the x-axis at
'x' equals 0 and 'x' equals 2.
If I now want to compute this
volume as I rotate the region
'R' about the y-axis--
see, I'm going to rotate
this about the y-axis.
I want to find out what volume
is generated by this region
'R' in this case.
Remember I can use either
cylindrical shells or I can
use revolution here.
Notice the problem I'm
going to be in.
Notice that this particular
function is single valued but
not one-to-one.
When I try to find these two
'x' values I'm going to run
into multi-values.
I'm going to have to invert.
All sorts of computational
skills are going to
come into play here.
On the other hand, if I take my
generating element parallel
to the y-axis, I have a very
simple expression for this,
and now that indicates what?
By the method of cylindrical
shells, this will be the
integral from 0 to 2.
The generating arm is 'x', so
that cuts out '2 pi x'.
The height is 'y', which
is '2x - x squared'.
The thickness is 'dx'.
In other words, mechanically
I must evaluate
this particular integral.
OK?
At any rate, it's factoring
out the 2 pi and just
observing that the
integral of '2 x
squared' is '2/3 x cubed'.
The integral of 'x'
to the fourth is
'1/4 'x to the 4th''.
Evaluating that between
0 and 2, I get 2 pi
times 16/3 minus 4.
The lower limit is 0 here.
This just comes out to be 16
minus 12, 4/3 times 2 pi.
That's 8 pi over 3.
By the way, before I go any
further with this, let's make
the interesting observation.
See, 8 pi over 3 is the volume
generated by this whole thing
being revolved about
the y-axis.
If I'd drawn in this line, which
is a line of symmetry,
notice that these two
areas are congruent.
These two regions
are congruent.
However, it's also interesting
to observe that the volume
generated by this piece as you
revolve it about the y-axis is
not twice the volume generated
by this piece.
See, notice that the integral
from 0 to 1-- in other words,
if we just took this region
here, integrated this from 0
to 1, we would get 5/6, 2/3
minus 1/4 times 2 pi, 5/6.
And if we double that,
we would get 5/3.
In other words, this
area is 5/6.
Double it would be
5 pi over 6.
Double it would be 5 pi over 3,
and 5 pi over 3 is not the
same as 8 pi over 3.
The thing to keep in mind here
is notice how the distance
comes in again.
You see, for example, these two
lines here are symmetric
with respect to the
line 'x' equals 1.
But notice that this generates a
much larger volume than this
because its generating
arm is longer.
It's further away.
But at any rate, that's
just an aside.
Notice how by the method of
cylindrical shells, we
determine the volume
is 8 pi over 3.
Suppose we'd wanted to do this
by the solid method-- the
solid revolution method.
Notice that we would first
have to invert this
relationship.
We would first have to solve
for 'x' in terms of 'y'.
Notice that 'y' equals '2x - x
squared' is the same as saying
that ''x squared'
- 2x + y' is 0.
Using the quadratic formula, we
can solve for 'x', and we
now find that 'x' is 1 plus the
square root of '1 - y' or
1 minus the square
root of '1 - y'.
What that means, by the way,
geometrically, is simply this.
For a given value of 'y', there
are two values of 'x'
located symmetrically with
respect to 'x' equals 1.
See, they're on symmetrical
portions.
Well, this doesn't make
that much difference.
The thing now is what?
What is my cross-sectional
area?
My cross-sectional area is pi
times this length squared
minus pi times this
length squared.
That's pi times 1 plus the
square root of ''1 - y'
squared' minus pi times the
square root of 1 minus the
square root of ''1
- y' squared'.
When I square this and subtract,
all but the middle
term drops out.
In other words, I have twice
the square root of '1 - y'
here minus twice the square
root of '1 - y' here.
When I subtract, I get 4 times
the square root of '1 - y'.
I multiply that by pi.
That's my cross-sectional
area.
And now to find the volume, I
just integrate that as 'y'
goes from 0 to 1.
You see, and if I carry out
this integration, noticing
that the integral of ''1 - y'
to the 1/2' is minus 2/3.
Remember, the derivative of
'1 - y' with respect to
'y' is minus 1.
''1 - y' to the 3/2'.
Evaluate that between 0 and 1.
The upper limit gives me 0.
The lower limit is minus 2/3.
I subtract the lower limit.
It gives me 2/3.
4 pi times 2/3 is 8 pi
over 3, the same
answer as I got before.
Notice, by the way, that
this was messy, but we
could handle it.
If this had been
much tougher--
say a 6 over here or something
like that instead of a 2--
how would we have solved for
'x' in terms of 'y'?
You see, in other words, this
would have been a case where
the shell method would have been
necessitated because of
the impossibility
of the algebra.
But at any rate, we have plenty
of opportunity to
illustrate that in terms of
exercises and supplementary
notes and reading material
and what have you.
That is actually the
easiest part.
The hard part is to understand
the significance of what's
going on, so I thought that to
summarize today's lecture,
let's keep in mind that whether
you call it area or
whether you call it volume or
whether you call it distance
traveled in velocity, the fact
remains that if 'f' is a
function continuous on the
closed interval from 'a' to
'b', and we partition that
interval into 'n' parts, and
we form the sum as 'k' goes from
1 to 'n', 'f of 'c sub
k'' times 'delta x sub k', where
'c sub k' is in the k-th
interval, and 'delta x sub
k' is just 'x sub k'
minus 'x sub 'k - 1''.
If we take that limit as the
largest 'delta x' approaches 0
and call that 'Q', that
limit 'Q' exists.
Symbolically, it's written by
the definite integral from 'a'
to 'b', ''f of x' dx', and,
more to the point, if you
happen to know differential
calculus, you can compute 'Q'
just by computing 'G of b'
minus 'G of a', where 'G
prime' is any function whose
derivative is 'f'.
OK?
Now again, this is why I'm
calling it a summary.
If you separate this out from
all of the computational stuff
that we did in today's lecture,
this is the part
that's left.
OK?
And what I want to do next
time is to show you that
things are not quite this
straightforward all the time,
that certain nice things have
been happening here that allow
us, essentially, to get
away with murder.
And what I mean by that will
become clearer next time, but
until next time then goodbye.
MALE ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video
was provided by the Gabriella
and Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.